so the promise the essential promise of
america is equal treatment under the law
we're all citizens and we are judged
equally for what we do
that's the most important thing we have
and it's going away and is if you need
more evidence consider this one of the
biggest investment firms in the country
just announced it will impose strict
racial discrimination in its hiring
state street global advisors has
informed its managers they will need
express permission before hiring white
men not because white male applicants
aren't qualified to do the job no but
because they are white and they are male
so at state street global advisors your
color can disqualify you from employment
the company has said that explicitly
now it's worth remembering that in
addition to being immoral obviously this
is illegal under federal law and if you
have any questions about that check the
mandatory labor law poster that hangs by
law in every break room in every office
in america and it will tell you it is
illegal to discriminate against people
on the basis of their race and hiring
period
federal law could not be clearer about
that and yet here's the amazing thing
the so-called civil rights division at
joe biden's justice department has not
said a word about this and they're never
going to they're too busy forcing boys
onto girls soccer teams and making
certain no one tries to put anchor mama
back on pancake syrup
so for now anyway state street will not
face the felony charges it so badly
deserves
so you've got to wonder if white men are
so bad that you need new rules to keep
them out of your workplace then why is
the parent company of state street run
by one of them
that man's name is ronald p o'hanley and
as you can see from the picture on your
screen he is both pale and male
we took a look at ron pio hanley's
official bio this afternoon technically
it's inaccurate and then it does not
describe him as a jowly racist buffoon
but it does concede that he was once a
partner at mckinsey and company and that
he is quote deeply involved in industry
efforts around climate corporate
governance and diversity and inclusion
of course he is and he's also led
several initiatives on gender equality
needless to say as if the parody
couldn't be more perfect we also learned
that ronald hanley is a quote avid
offshore sailboat racer
he's got his own offshore racing boat
called privateer with his own captain to
sail it this is mr diversity and
inclusion
keep in mind that this is the guy
telling your son who's done nothing
wrong who just wants to work that he
can't have a job because he was born the
wrong color which happens to be the same
color that ron p o hanley is
it's all pretty amazing so here's our
challenge mr ron p.o hanley and we hope
he's listening tonight
if you're going to start building
apartheid in this country
you go first
quit your stupid job and give it to a
woman of color
transfer your entire personal portfolio
including your multiple homes to the
black lives matter foundation give your
little sailboat to a deserving family of
haitian immigrants and then start over
from scratch at zero under the rules you
are now imposing on this generation of
young people
and we'll see how you do ron pohanley
that would be equity
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else